let's hear from a few more people
hopefully with functioning audio devices
we take calls on Fridays via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to try Thai from
Connecticut Ty you know because you're
from Connecticut I have a good feeling
that our connection is going to work
work beautifully are you there can you
talk to me today
okay I can hear you but it's almost like
you're muttering so low that I don't
know what you're talking about
sorry I got it I thought I got a little
bit of a deep voice okay that's I now I
can hear you perfectly
yeah I mean we gotta get this this stuff
straight man what's what's up with your
boy Pete booty judge
[Music]
you think he's a favorable candidate in
the wake of like the airline stuff
the railroad stuff
uh I'm not really a fan of his past like
where are you coming from from that end
all right let's go through those what
what about his past are you not a fan of
uh I think that the fact that he comes
from like
and like with the corporate realm with
the McKinsey stuff I think that
um
I think that whole when he was mayor
whatever the whole like there's like the
two high-ranking
like police administrator or something
like that and like one was black one was
white I can remember the exact story but
I think they were saying like uh the
like I was saying racist stuff the black
guy had reported documented it or
whatever
and like Pete ended up firing
to a black cop and there's a huge uproar
or whatever
okay I I admit I'm not familiar with
that particular story but okay so
there's a so there's a couple things
what about like the ports thing what
what about it was Buddha judge's fault I
guess
I don't think the
like the Manifest well my understanding
was is that like the railroad workers
the
um
the pilots
uh were fatigued wait a second what does
this have to do with ports what are you
talking about
when you say ports you mean airports no
no you're talking about the shipping
right the the boats
I mentioned that I mentioned the
Airlines and
um oh and trains you said
and the railroad uh like strike thing
that uh Congress like dismantled
um listen I'll just skip to the chase
okay as I've said before it's I just
think that I think more to meet the
workers it's not that I think Pete
bootage is the Uber Progressive it's not
that I think he has a perfect history
I've listed Pete butterjudge along with
others who I think are sort of a mold
that would be an interesting way for
Democrats to go in the next couple of
election cycles and what I mean by that
is they are younger
they are really really good in media and
debate situations they have a
ruthlessness in terms of their dealing
with Republicans that I think has been
missing for a little bit which I think
would be good and so it's not I've said
before it's not oh I think Buddha judges
the you know God's gift to Progressive
politics it's I think that these are the
types of folks uh I like Jamie Raskin I
like John awesome Katie Porter Gavin
Newsome
what are you talking about
who do you think is God's Gift of
progressive politics right now honestly
right I can't think of anybody right now
there's no one really that I'm fanboying
over I have to tell you
all right can I ask one more quick
question what do you think that in this
upcoming presidential election the
Democratic party should be offering
um black Americans
black Americans specifically or just
policy that
we're talking over each other I'm going
to let you go and I'll just answer
offline because I'm having I'm
struggling to get a word in edgewise
um I would like to see if Biden runs for
re-election or if he doesn't and we see
a um a democratic a different Democratic
candidate I want to see
um a tax reform plan
that will actually both simplify the tax
code but will be abundantly clear that
it is good for the middle class and it
will directly attach tax uh the richest
Americans I would like to see a serious
proposal on a paid family uh paternity
leave paid paternity and maternity leave
um period I would like to see
um something credible and serious on
what is the next step on health care so
it doesn't have to be we're going from
Obamacare to single-payer for everybody
I don't know that that would be credible
I don't know it would pass but I would
like to see another maybe even do it as
like a Medicaid expansion where we again
raise the income level at which people
will qualify fold more people in uh you
know I will outline what my my top wish
list would be
um sometime closer to when the primaries
really get going all right let's speak
to some other people why don't we go
next to a Christian from Edmonton
Christian welcome to the program what's
on your mind today
David yes sir yes a tear dreaming down
my face right now you're in tears now I
know it right now uh first of all I just
wanted to address a critical issue from
the bigly news a few weeks ago
um I finished your physical over the
weekend and I wanted to get right into
the knit and gritty for you and all your
valuable listeners yeah you are
currently six foot three inches tall and
239 pounds
just like Trump it's shocking yeah
big big strong man
you also passed the Montreal cognitive
IQ test like nobody else even knew was
possible
somehow the tiger nor the elephant
stumped you yeah okay I also found that
if you didn't go to Starbucks when you
were heading home from Montreal yeah
that last time you could probably have
lived to 600 years old yeah I do think
I'm sorry for that you know I know
you're kidding I do think that that one
Starbucks stop over the last 20 years
probably did hurt me in some way and in
all seriousness Christian
people know it's been 20 years since I
went to Starbucks or Dunkin Donuts in
the last year due to extenuating
circumstances I've gotten a coffee at
both it was terrible it really is
terrible and I'm trying to have an open
mind I'm not trying to be like a third
wave coffee snob or anything like that
the Starbucks coffee was terrible and
the Dunkin coffee was terrible it was
just horrifyingly bad coffee
I mean that's the benefit of having your
own home set up right yeah you set the
bar too high for everywhere you go I
know it I know it but anyway uh was
there anything else you had for me today
yeah
um I just wanted to say congrats on
being a dad it's it's great progress um
my my boy is about two years old now and
it's super cool so I'm excited for you
to see see your daughter yeah the
sleeping is getting much better we're
now she can push like for a 12-hour
sleep you know and she's only she's not
even she's eight months so I think that
that bodes well for the future hopefully
anyway
yeah developmentally as well that's
going to be big big steps that she's
gonna go through so that's awesome to
hear all right well thank you Christian
I appreciate the clean bill health
thanks David all right there is
Christian from Edmonton